usually conspiracy theories start with
like a kernel of truth you know hold on
okay there's a kernel of truth but
that's really not that absurd and then
it goes into the absurd well the little
small kernel of truth here is pedophile
island
question of the day really simple here
epstein suicide
your thoughts really i want to hear
because there's so many different
theories so
first off the epstein case is so
outlandish obviously
so many moving parts and there are
already so many conspiracies relating to
it that it's hard to keep track
yeah very so this segment today i i want
to make sure that you
is designed to stick with only the
verifiable facts that we know right okay
and i encourage you to check out all the
sources that we list here for yourself
and when i'm offering my opinion
i will issue a disclaimer okay
and i should say that at the time of
this taping there's emerging evidence
that this was really a simple error from
the geek squad employee who installed
the video cameras
and that was the only one that's the
only one everything else is 100 factual
i promise
so let's go down fact okay jeffrey
epstein billionaire who ran a child
prostitution ring connected to some of
the most powerful people in the world
and he had an actual pedophile island
wow
an island yep completely pagan looking
temples full of mattresses i think we
have b-roll of it here
so caution here disclaimer my opinion
on its surface that sounds pretty bad
yeah
all right so the fifth fact i think
everyone needs to know epstein almost
got away with it
okay yeah think about this for a second
for running a child prostitution ring
and
raping underage girls he was sentenced
to 18 months he didn't even serve that
in a private wing of the the palm beach
county stockade okay he was allowed to
leave the jail on work release for up to
12 hours a day six days a week the
florida attorney general alexander costa
he uh he was the one who cut the
non-profit the deal and he said that it
was because he had been told to back off
that epstein was above his pay grade uh
i think the exact quote is i was told
epstein belonged to intelligence
and to leave it alone the sheriff's
office they actually received 128
thousand dollars from epstein's
nonprofit
to pay for extra services during his
work release um
he was monitored by permit deputies
whose overtime by the way was paid by
epstein his cell door was left unlocked
he also accepted mail female visitors in
a separate office with the door closed
prison staff did not supervise
oh my gosh billionaire caught red-handed
running a child hooker ring
effectively i don't want to say hooker
because they weren't willing i don't
know i don't know if the difference
between prostitution ring or hooker
rings hookers it sounds like there'd be
a willing you know
pimp i think hooker and prostitution are
interchangeable i don't know i listen to
110th street and i love the song so i
feel like i know the difference i've
heard of white americans are out of
touch with black culture that's not me
not you
so raping molesting over a hundred girls
he gets 13 months in effectively a
private resort now opinion disclaimer
seems to me like here his money and
connections may have led to favorable
treatment
opinion maybe don't look for a source on
that no that's just stephen doing what
steven do
he was arrested more recently because
this a lot of people say well why was he
arrested recently if that was
actually because of miami herald tracked
down one of the women who he abused
published an expose then he was arrested
on new charges i believe it was uh it
was july
that's one fact okay fact number four no
one really knows and i've been
researching this for the last 48 hours
no one really knows how this guy made
his fortune supposedly over a billion
dollars yeah uh he ran a money
management business and it specialized
in investments for billionaires
what's crazy about this is he's not he
wasn't known as a savvy investor he
wasn't like a warren buffett
so billionaires just also said well okay
you're gonna have an investment fund for
us billionaires
who else what other money have you
managed none you'll be my first
yeah that's a great salesperson so
opinion disclaimer
looking at the evidence it seems opinion
youtube okay
not a conspiracy it seems like blackmail
could have played maybe a row a little
bit
now keep in mind his mansion this is the
mansion we would hold parties with
celebrities politicians underage girls
um when it was first rated law
enforcement they found
many hidden cameras do you know how many
hidden cameras no many
many they know this house was more
recently rated again first off
you know raid my house once shame on you
[Laughter]
they found a lot safe with cds labeled
young and
names inserted their young name plus
name which again would suggest that it
could be
blackmail related why would you have all
of these cameras and label it
oh yeah this person plus this person and
you have it archived unless he was just
like recording to watch later for
his own gratification who knows he
doesn't need to he has a he has a
harem i don't know he's a sick puppy he
was
i have no idea he's the kind of guy who
would ignore the needs of his harem just
to watch tapes
yeah you're a selfish lover epstein was
we expected to come out in the trial
that's what's really sad and all this we
expected the world to understand what a
selfish lover episode was and now we'll
never know
we'll never know by the way 77 million
dollar mansion that we just i think we
just uh showed you was transferred
epstein by a rich investor for
zero dollars oh nothing here's what
bothers me about this
maybe let's assume that maybe it turned
out to be true this is a
rich and powerful man who owned
a pedophile island he had a cabal of
actors and politicians like isn't that
enough
that should be the crap that you're were
trying to read into in the jay-z
and rihanna music is like is that
illuminati i think it is amazing this is
worse than all of it it's like no no we
know
charge with pedophile island you're like
wait a second
i think this is bigger how does it get
bigger
the people involved stephen the people
all right fact number three asking
questions
just what are you jesse mentioned i'm
just asking the question have you
know your facts fluoride in the tap
all right uh this is something else
something that really should
seem damning uh clinton and the lolita
express so epstein a private jet known
as the lolita express
that made many trips to his pedophile
island here's a clip this woman shantae
davis took inside edition inside this
named after the iconic fictional
character from the book
and movie epstein allegedly used a
private jet to fly
underage girls to sex parties shantae
was epstein's personal masseuse
on almost every trip that i did go on
there were young girls around
biggest surprise is that's a redhead
irish lady named sean tay yeah who
yeah also the way he answered that
private sex island it's like the person
who's kind of outside edition was
uncomfortable saying it yeah sex island
it was noted that bill clinton tried to
yes uh by the way hit the notification
bell uh join michael if you haven't yet
already get access to the entire daily
show you don't get here on youtube
and of course uh subscribe on itunes uh
a lot of squad.com club and itunes and
whatever who cares so the clintons were
really good buddies with epstein
uh he was a regular at the white house
when bill clinton was in office okay
uh here's something bill clinton claimed
he knew nothing of epstein's crimes
right
fair enough okay we we cannot verify
true nor can we refute that but he also
claimed that he'd only flown
on the plane four times that's a lie lie
the flight logs show clinton taking a
total of i want to make sure i get this
right yeah 27 flights on
six separate trips that's not four and
here's what's odd
there were no secret service agents
listed on the trip manifest but many
random women which really shouldn't be
odd considering the subject at
the end here's something else he wasn't
alone there are a lot of high profile
celebrities and uh
prince andrew by the way i didn't really
know a whole lot about prince andrew and
tilda so that's how i'll remember him
um they were paling around underage
girls like i don't care about princes
uh free from this and of course we want
to get to the suicide
in the cell that's obviously fact number
one but here's another fact number two
you need to know
donald trump's president donald trump's
relationship with epstein this to be
fair
president trump he did have a
relationship with epstein he did
comparatively though it was very casual
and ended with trump kicking epstein out
of mar-a-lago
for sexually assaulting an underage girl
here are the court documents
you can see them yourself okay donald
trump had a problem with it he made sure
that he was no longer welcome and knew
it and though the media reported that
trump flirted with one of the girls at
epstein's mansion so you've probably
heard this she actually came out
and proactively corrected the record and
said that not only had trump not had sex
with her or any of epstein's other girls
she also said he never even flirted with
her and that's important to know because
the me
the media is going okay so this sex
island was was a trump they're saying no
no trump wasn't even trump
no trump wasn't even trump he wasn't
even there he didn't want to be trump
but anonymous trump
anonymous can you say trump guess it no
not the opposite from trump
i think this is what they they wanted to
go with trump and here's opinion
trump we know likely cheated on at least
one of his multiple wives okay
yeah but let's be honest this is opinion
he traded his older wife for a slightly
younger model i traded in a 55 year old
wife i think like a 35 or 37 year old
it's crappy but not perverse clinton
cheated on his wife with a 22 year old
intern and it is well known that bill
clinton really had a preference for
incredibly young women
yeah really young women this should
really be a problem for the clintons and
yet
all we're hearing is trump like you said
they really want it so
bad for trump to be in this right and
this to be a problem they got all upset
about the uh
clinton body count was trending yeah so
yeah they tried to get trump
and then all of a sudden it was gone and
the body count just consists of the the
the bodies of the dreams of all the
hillary clinton voters that's all it is
let the bodies hit the floor let the
bodies hit the
floor
with the sickness
i can see him doing this i have no idea
what's going on here oh
fact number one that you want to know
the suicide cape spoiler alert
some shady circumstances here so uh the
fbi inspector general they're both
investigating the circumstances of the
suicide you probably know that congress
most likely launched an investigation
here's the thing they're going to launch
an investigation
um i think oh no we have a clip chank
wieger of the young turks
uh has a favorite to lead the
investigation okay
uh so who's doing the investigation
that's the important part right okay
fair enough so that gets to uh solution
number two
aoc
[Laughter]
we're way past april first like this is
what yeah yeah
what are the qualifications zero
but i like her so i think that she
should be interested what are you
talking
about and actually i think we're getting
word uh our source in congress uh
leaked that the congresswoman i guess we
actually have recording of the audio
phone call for collecting facts as we
speak
oh so he was like a kid's doctor and
this is like a malpractice thing no no
miss cortez that's a pediatrician
epstein was a pedophile
oh so like a feet doctor no no that's a
podiatrist
epstein was a pedophile not a doctor a
criminal
oh so like he was jaywalking that's a
pedestrian moving violation
epstein was a pedophile ped oh file he
liked to be inappropriate with minors
without their consent
oh so like joe biden
she's more astute than i was giving her
credit for here's something else that
shows how out of touch
the media is with this no joke the right
obviously thinks
that uh the right obviously
people here obviously the left and the
right are calling for investigation
saying that this is shady now you just
have people on the right saying there's
a clinton body account then you have
people in the left saying
donald trump is president he had a
relationship but the fact that the only
people saying that
there's nothing to see here is the media
both people
on the left far left and far right and
everyone in between except for those in
the elitist media
want to see some they want to see some
answers here yeah
and by the way as soon as this new case
began everyone this is important people
to know
like who could have seen this coming
every single person on twitter with an
egg yeah yeah they were joking that he
was going to
die by apparent suicide in jail you know
two shots to the back of the head yeah
it's like start the clock
just just this is something really
important people don't know just on
friday
it was friday that documents were
unsealed yeah and it looked like
epstein's
the high-profile friends they were going
to be called in to testify yeah
the next morning epstein was found dead
in his cell
and by the way it turns out he was taken
off suicide watch this is true i'm
trying to make sure that we clarify
there's some conspiracy
this is absolutely true he's taken off
suicide watch even after they
claim that he had an attempted suicide
um he should have been checked on every
30 minutes by security guards according
to prison regulations that's what was
supposed to happen they didn't and they
couldn't find the video
what that's it i know you think i was
going to say more no that's enough
that's it he was in his set he was found
in the cell not the bathroom so there
should be video but there isn't
according to sources that there are
there's no footage the medical examiner
by the way has ruled the cause of death
pending
this like oh the death is pending the
coroner's like we don't have enough
information isn't that what
isn't that what you're paid for he hung
himself how are we gonna know like
it's like someone throwing it like going
into a doctor yeah it's like i'm sorry
there's nothing you can
you're gonna die so well hold on a
second what about prilosec
uh get you wanna try that what do you
think no it's your job you tell me
what do i do what are my options doug i
don't know what do you want like you
wanna go for ice cream later no you're
the doctor
that's why i'm here oh my gosh all right
so
too convenient we've talked so putting
on my opinion hat here all right when
we're talking about do i think that
there's something
i think if someone can actually go back
to my first show ever the radio when we
were on radio before we were even
syndicated back
just in wham and detroit ann arbor i
said i'm not a conspiratorial guy
if you're looking for that kind of a
radio show this isn't the show for you
except you know i think the clinton's
killed some people
and i kind of joked about it yeah but
gun to your head what
okay yeah foster brown seth rich
i mean now epstein what is the
mathematical probability
this is the thing like right now we
don't have to spend 24 to 50 million
taxpayer dollars on an investigation
just you know what just get the video
how about that just get the video and
how about this
just let's say it costs us an extra 250
000
put a couple extra corners on it put a
couple extra medical examiners on it so
that you come back with an answer that
isn't
pending but you come back with an answer
that isn't well what do you think
i do not think that this is i think it's
a conspiracy to go off too far
it is and say okay cia but it's true it
is not
if you think that you're crazy for
thinking about this conspiratorially
when this guy this
as soon as the doc as soon as these
documents are unsealed
we start getting information and this
guy is rubbed out
you are not crazy this is not just some
outlandish conspiracy theory
because it starts with usually
conspiracy theories start with like a
kernel of truth
you know hold on okay there's a kernel
of truth but that's really not that
absurd
and then it goes into the absurd well
the little small kernel of truth here is
pedophile
island it's pedophile
island that's the starting point okay
it's bad enough we are not crazy for
thinking there's a conspiracy
with the guy who died alone in his cell
who ran
an island for pedophiles hey there
youtube viewer if you like this video
click
one of these other videos playing in a
box up there and hit subscribe or the
notification bell if you're already
subscribed so you can
find out about our new non-controversial
videos which don't ruffle any feathers
and of course are not a violation of
youtube's algorithms
everyone's welcome here except
i don't know if we are but it's our
channel
not sure how that works